il y a quelques années j'étais
journaliste et j'ai décidé d'interviewer
Sébastien Chabal sauf qu'à l'époque
Chabal il est un peu fâché avec les
journalistes je lui propose un conceptte
juste pour lui moi je lui pose des
questions provocquantes mais lui il a le
droit de me répondre comme il veut on le
rejoint à l'entraînement avec un de mes
collègues vous allez entendre sa voix à
un moment si vous faites attention dans
la vidéo vous me direz si vous l'avez
reconnu ça va aller et puis un an plus
tard comme j'en avais pas eu assez et
que je voulais Mar revanche j'y suis
retourné avec deux collègues mais Chabal
il a ramené ses collègues aussi donc bah
il y avait Sébastien évidemment il y
avait aussi Albert vou vouli un
international fidien et puis Karim gzal
qui fait maintenant partie du staff de
l'équipe de France de rugby TR
[Musique]
fu pour la petite histoire après ça j'ai
eu le plus gros bleu de ma vie sur la
cuisse et je me suis dit que finalement
faire des vidéos sur la santé c'était
peut-être moins dangereux alors est-ce
que vous avez entendu la voix de mon
collègue qui filme la première vidéo si
vous l'avez reconnu dites-le-moi dans
les commentaires allez les bleus dans 4
ans du coup